das Bürgergeld ist eines der Top Themen
im Deutschen Bundestag es gab schon eine
Reihe von Debatten in der nächsten Woche
steht das Thema wieder auf der
Tagesordnung des Deutschen Bundestages
und ich habe festgestellt und viele
meiner Kollegen auch ist dass die
ampelregierung äußerst dünnhäutig auf
Kritik am Bürgergeld reagiert um es
vielleicht vorweg zu sagen wir als Union
sehen das Bürgergeld kritisch es ist
nicht zielführend es ist ungerecht und
das sendet die völlig falschen Signale
und jetzt könnte man meinen ja es
verwundert nicht unbedingt dass die
Opposition nicht die Meinung der
Regierung teilt was wir aber beobachten
ist dass unsere Kritik und auch die
Kritik von anderen in der Öffentlichkeit
moralisch abgewertet wird ich finde dass
das hilft nicht der Debatte im Gegenteil
wir sollten sachliche Argumente
austauschen und ich finde auch die Ampel
muss sich diese Kritik gefallen lassen
denn am Ende des Tages fühlen sich sonst
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger mit ihrer
Kritik vielleicht nicht gehört im
Deutschen Bundestag